once he goes under your instinct should
have been to just go
listen to this this is a bad bad bad one
very bad oh no don't laugh don't even
laugh watch this whole video Nick Nick
we're gonna keep my head don't laugh all
right I'm just so tired son of a [__]
so in Guyana there's a 15 year old girl
that's being charged as an adult where's
Guyana
um Ghana
it is in
isn't it South America yes yeah it's
like uh or Central nice South America
okay okay let's go look on those Maps
Georgetown is the capital oh very cool
um
so she's it's a 15 year old girl she's
being charged as an adult for the murder
of 19 people oh [__] how do you think
she accomplished this terrible 19
uh poison food motive what do you think
was that right no okay she lured them in
with both think of the how she did it
and why sexual
um promiscuity like that's what they
thought they were going to be yeah and
then it turns out
19 of them okay you guys are all gonna
get pleasure close your eyes takes away
all the throat I think she did the old
like uh car parked on the side of the
road trick and then opened the hood and
she's probably wearing like a mini skirt
like this and this was trying to catch a
pervert and then I need help and then
when they go and help she [__] took
the car battery
oh okay hitchhiker okay that's you know
what that's along the lines of of
creativity it is that complex but here's
the caveat she all 19 at the same time
whoa at the same time same time dude
they went to one of those blindfolded
dinners and she was hosting it like a
murder mystery oh I did yeah but you
know I did that dark yeah it's oh yeah
killed him while they're eating are they
all she's John Wick similar demographic
all 19. uh they're all
um men yeah they're all old dudes
they're all dudes yeah guys she's 15
years old yeah they're all within her
same age range but in South America but
it's a guy and girl yeah and maybe
there is one boy that was like five
years old or something but I know what
happened that doesn't that doesn't help
she tried out for the synchronized swim
team and she didn't get it so she went
to go see them at the pool and then she
threw the car battery in the pool this
happens all the time it's very common
and then there was a five-year-old that
was swimming in there too it happens
three thousand dollars
related to White you said they were all
they were all around the same age I ages
12 to 18 yeah
oh is that a school it sounds like
schooling what's School related yeah it
sounds like some classmate [__] it's
School related it's not a mass shooting
is it part of Aquatics or not yeah we
need to know if it's a quantity a lot of
Aquatics if anything
it's related to the opposite what's the
opposite Inspire products
she burned she burned them all
chemical burns
so she was staying at a dormitory for
the school she got her phone taken away
it's always the phone angry about it
that she burned down the dormitory and
19 people died oh my so how did she do
it what kind of phone was it
and then walk up and down the hallway
and then light it and then lock the door
to that Wing it's oh so the doors are
locked from the inside to prevent girls
from going to hang out with boys but
that's dangerous that's smart yeah I
mean guyana's got a different fire code
I guess oh for sure whoa damn they
didn't plan for a fire yeah it's at a
secondary school and uh it doesn't say
exactly how she like did it all but damn
yeah she's being tried and as an adult
dude you're seeing if you kill 19 people
I think you should dude you know what's
effed up I think they allow phones in
jail I think they just sneak them in
with the booties so she really still got
what she wanted she just got wanted her
phone I think they sneak it in the booty
hole you can get anything in there you
think she's a good kid overall though
probably I wonder how she burned it down
though
she was never a spanked that's an
obvious yeah you think she she showed
signs of being assigned see the GPA
that's a good question though because
how did she burn it down if she didn't
have her phone she couldn't even Google
how to do it yep
and I I'm wondering like if she only
meant to burn a trash can and then it
turned into a massive fire and it was an
accident or it was like Bart scenario
where she intended on [__] burning
the whole thing down Joe if you were a
judge and she her intention was only to
burn the trash can and she killed 19
people how would you punish her I
wouldn't try her as adult yeah she would
still go to jail let's give her 15 round
houses I don't think she's a I don't
think she's a psychopath
if she was oh no that's my I'm raising
my hand but if she if she really if I
can prove that intent wise she was she's
a psychopath and and she was [__]
like that yeah then we need to keep her
out of society you know yeah what's up
Steve how was burned I would burn her
trash can oh [__]
should we put should we leave that in
can we send her a trash can an eye for
an eye do JK win if she's she's so
they're um they're gonna figure out if
she's guilty or not of this but if she
is life in prison is the most they can
do really it's 25 years right or is it
actually no this is a different country
yeah I don't know damn I don't know if
it is because here life just means 25
years yeah but I saw this sentencing in
Florida that's why some people get like
10 life sentences oh yeah in Florida
they go uh I saw this court case right
and at the end he goes sir I'm giving
you life in prison this is Florida life
means life and then he went on to
describing every day every month every
year of your life you'll be in the same
place and he was describing like a cold
steel toilet that's kind of right he was
like explaining every single detail of
how his life will play out and he wasn't
the only way you're gonna give freedom
is when you finally die of old age in
prison that sounds
because in California a big old life in
prison you go no
no here and Parole and you burned down a
dorm and you like killed 15 people and
on top of that you [__] skin the
grandma alive and you only get a new
iPhone upgrade every two years yeah oh
and like no and the girls were like oh
my God next day they release you they're
like actually you know what you're good
yeah in California they're like you're
only skinned Grandma alive that's it
well how old was the grandma yeah we'll
let you go yeah it's not he patronize
you I know they're like again you
punched another grandma again that was a
grandma Republican oh she was oh she's
fine oh good yeah they managed to rescue
20 other students from the fire though
luckily so it could have been way more
does this [__] even know that she were
those 19 heavy sleepers
if you want your phone back why would
you set fire to the building that has
your phone in it yeah are you an idiot
what are you [__] mean
there goes all your apps Psychopaths I
think she's stupid what do you think she
does on her phone what do you think her
favorite apps are I think she plays a
lot of Marvel snap
Fruit Ninja card game she was like on
the last level and they literally took
it away right before
she's just doing this on her phone
[__] Bejeweled
is sick here's a picture Candy Crush is
fire oh my God so it's charred dude it's
it's gone when I hear stories like this
I'm like
damn dude I don't really know if I have
kids do I want to send them off to
school
well not in Guyana where the fire code
allows for like do you have those
feelings about taika like all right like
he's in he's away from you guys with a
bunch of [__] morons
classmates and administration and
teachers
and then you're just leaving him there
well stats show stats show
um home life is 70 of the influence so
like if your home life is good you can
grow up in the hood of stuff hoods and
your kid will be successful yeah but the
whole life yeah but 30 but the whole
life but if you if you go to Beverly
Hills High School I don't know just some
stereotypical really good school and
your home life is not good chances are
they're gonna be [__] so home life is
way more important than the school but
home life doesn't protect them from a
[__] door that locks from the outside
I freak freak accidents like if you
really understand statistics that's 30
scariest but yeah that's true yeah
that's true so that has nothing to do
with yeah it's what you did yes idiot
policy that's what I'm saying is like
how do you protect your kids from they
could be doing everything right but the
[__] system is idiotic so it's like
but that's also like your kid being in
the car with you on the freeway in an
airplane yeah like Albertsons it's like
not my kid that's all I have to say that
yeah it's not a good point yeah
well at least we die together yeah you
know what I mean yeah that's true or
maybe we can be an accident and I'll
just die and they won't but still
I guess this is just weird I think with
my Tendencies I'd probably kill my kid
before
I almost drowned Tycoon before I even
turned two what do you mean said this
clip Geo so you went to hey
100 times
we went to um have you guys been to
sharks Cove in the OC yeah it's dope
it's dope right it's like a little
u-shaped horse feels like a little
Hawaii there yeah and it's like
horseshoe little thing so it's a Cove so
there's zero waves that's why people
love bringing their kids there because
there's zero away it's just calm right
and then I go there with taika he's not
even two years old yeah he's maybe like
one or one and a half he has a little
life vest on so we're just in the water
just having a good old time and then you
know like slowly I let him float around
he's bouncing around having a good old
time and literally just one second where
I like look away for something a wave
forms in a place that has no waves yeah
the wave the ocean has waves and it
turned into [__] a three four foot
wave
comes out of nowhere knocks them away
from me so my hand's not on the life
vest anymore knocks them out of my hand
and I see uh upside down baby him just
disappear oh [__] I'm like oh [__] so I
jumped this jump over here but I'm
actually more scared of Geo than
anything so I'm like I need to get this
[__] no matter what
and then I see his [__] back the back
of his life oh [__] come back up like
this
and then I'm like oh my God I grab them
I pick him out of the water and you see
his eyes go like I've only been on this
Earth for a year and I don't know what
the [__] just happened and I'm like oh
my God
oh my God and then he starts crying I'm
like oh I felt so bad that like how do
we how do waves form in a waveless beach
and then
I almost drowned his ass I felt so bad
and I'm like this is it'll probably die
in my hands not to criticize the beach
no you oh but you have some ice cream
once he goes under your instinct should
have been to just go
[Laughter]
damn you
[Music]
foreign